what is the highest common factor of two
numbers
how is HCF of numbers computed yes it's
commonly referred to as the HCF let's
say we want to find the HCF of eight and
twelve to know how the HCF is computed
we just need to understand the meaning
of these three words highest common and
factor look at the three words highest
common and factor so let's first find
the factors of each of these numbers do
you remember how to find the factors of
a number yes we try to write it as all
possible products of two positive
numbers we look at eight first one
obvious way is to write it as one
multiplied by eight is eight divisible
by two
yes so we can also write it as two times
four it's not divisible by three and
four onwards is covered here that's it
we cannot write it in any other way so
we can say that the factors of 8 are 1 2
4 and 8 just like we found the factors
of 8 why don't you try finding the
factors of 12 to find the factors we
write 12 as all possible products of 2
positive numbers it can be written as 1
multiplied by 12 2 x 6 + 3 x 4 so the
factors of 12 are 1 2 3 4 6 and 12 in
the first step we found out the factors
of each of the numbers the next step is
common we look for common factors for
each of the numbers 1 is a factor common
to both the numbers 2 is also common and
4 is common as well 1 2 & 4 are common
factors to both these numbers and the
only word that remains is highest so we
look for the highest common factor among
all the common factors 4 is the highest
among these three numbers hence the
highest common factor of 8 and 12 is 4
let's quickly go through what we did
first we found out the factors of each
of the numbers then we found out the
common factors to both the numbers and
then we found out the highest common
factor the highest common factor is also
commonly known as the greatest common
divisor or the GCD even GCD means the
same thing
greatest is the same as the highest and
factors of a number are also their
divisors for example 4 is a divisor of 8
3 is a divisor of 12 that's the concept
of HCF or GCD but is this the best way
to solve for the HCF of two numbers we
cover that over the next few sessions